this is an exam paper from the
University of Cambridge it's part of a
course which is widely regarded as being
the most demanding undergraduate
mathematics course in Britain and that
is the mathematical tripos the tripos
comes in three parts spread over three
years and it is an old exam steeped in
Tradition and Prestige it was introduced
around
1790 and still challenges some of the
smartest students today some
mathematicians would like to see it
abolished but for now the tripos still
has a strong grip on English higher math
education so let's take a look at it
this is the exam that for over 200 years
has been seen as a leading test of
mental agility and stamina it's changed
a lot in that time but the current
iteration still contains all sorts of
really difficult questions it starts
with number Theory compute the continued
fraction expansion of the square root of
29 foreign then an analysis proof and
then a cryptography question describe
the Burly care Massey method for
breaking a cipher stream arising from a
linear feedback shift register this is
one of the four papers which a student
would take in their third year of the
tripos after this they can leave with a
bachelor's degree or do one more year of
study called part three to obtain a
masters of math you'll notice though
that this one exam paper contains
questions on everything from number
Theory to coding to statistics quantum
mechanics and Analysis it's more common
elsewhere to see these different areas
of math separated into different modular
exams where you only need to study for
one at a time that's not the case here
all of the subjects are considered
together but you do get to pick and
choose which questions to tackle this
approach allows students to go to
whatever courses and lectures they want
and then choose how they want to prepare
for the exam here's the list of courses
on offer in third year I'm drawn to see
what the exam questions look like for
some of these for example math of
machine learning this is the 2022
question they are asked to write down
and add a boost algorithm to say what is
meant by a convex Hull and a convex
combination of vectors what is meant by
the empirical ready maker complexity
here's the syllabus for the mathematics
of machine learning course to see the
other kind of ideas that go into this
math Cambridge now has many triposes for
the different subjects including an
English tripos and a natural sciences
one but it used to be just math the
original form of the exam was a debate
where students had to Wrangle with logic
but then it became what might be the
oldest written University exam in the
world the original test was called the
Senate house examination because that's
the name of the building where it was
taken the oldest copy of the exam that I
could find was this one from 1841 the
questions were also difficult but
different solve the following equations
and show that a quadratic equation
cannot have more than two roots prove
that in a spherical triangle any one
side is greater than the difference
between the two others enunciate and
prove the tenth Lemma of Newton's first
section they expected students to be
familiar with Newton's work in a way
that no student is today if I pull out
my handy principia we might be able to
get the answer to this one okay this
looks like Lemma 10 in the first section
the spaces which our body describes by a
finite Force urging it whether that
force is determined and immutable or is
continually augmented or continually
diminished are in the very beginning of
the motion to each other as the squares
of the times hmm the focus on Newton
does make sense since Newton did study
in Cambridge and heavily influenced the
British math scene give the arguments
for supposing the earth to be round and
on the supposition of its being a sphere
investigate a formula for calculating
approximately the dip of the horizon
this older exam was a true mental
agility and endurance test there are 12
papers to be taken two a day for six
days it's a week-long marathon answering
hundreds of questions for five and a
half hours a day students trained for it
like an Olympic sport the highest
scoring student was called the senior
Wrangler and became a minor celebrity I
found the scores for an exam in the
1860s which gives an idea of scoring
around this time and out of a possible
Mark of 17
000 the senior Wrangler scored only
about 7 600 second place scored about 4
100 and the lowest scoring candidate to
still pass scored just 237 points and
earned the special wooden spoon award
the 1841 results are listed here with
Stokes the senior Wrangler that is
George Stone now famous for the navier
Stokes equation in fluid mechanics and
Stokes theorem in Vector calculus you
might have been examined on those ideas
yourself and now you've seen the exact
exam questions Stokes faced as a student
let's compare some similar questions
from then and now given that this exam
took place before Einstein's work on
relativity we can't expect much of an
analog to this general relativity
question but there are plenty of
questions about Newtonian gravity
1841 was before we developed
astronomical spectroscopy or measured
the expansion of the universe so this
cosmology question would blow the mind
of even an 1841 senior Wrangler but wait
actually George Stokes apparently is
credited with inventing the fundamental
principles of spectroscopy
modern quantum mechanics wasn't to be
invented for another 60 years so we
won't see that but there are plenty of
questions about light and we won't find
much machine learning statistical
modeling or coding and cryptography in
the 1841 paper since there were no
computers
these are the best I could find to
resemble the modern number Theory and
Analysis questions training for the
tripos has historically involved
external coaching to help students
increase the speed that they can solve
and write out Solutions and the whole
process has been criticized for not
allowing enough time for a deep
understanding or to make investigations
which are important skills for
mathematician and the senior Wrangler
has not always turned out to be the most
distinguished mathematician later in
life one notable critic of the tripos
was g h Hardy ramanujan's Mentor Hardy
gave an address to the mathematical
Association in 1926 calling to abolish
the tripos completely he said that the
ability to show originality in
mathematics can't be tested under exam
conditions and so the exam reduces to a
kind of game a student can choose to
play the game with all their Force but
must realize they are putting their
mathematical development on hold to do
so the prestige and status of the tripos
forces many students to devote
everything to the game
Hadi isn't against exams in general and
knows they are useful to test students
but he wants exams that do not profess
to be more than a reasonable test of
certain hum drum qualities the quality
is worth testing on an exam would carry
any student at Cambridge to second class
and beyond that he does not believe in
recognizing differences of ability by
examination the tripos is an exam that
attempted to sort students right to the
top today students are no longer
publicly ranked in order but the senior
Wrangler is still acknowledged during
the reading of results at Senate house
students today might still relate to the
idea of having to put their real
mathematical Pursuits on hold in order
to play the game Hardy says if Einstein
had taken the tripos what would it
matter what place he took
students are driven to perform in the
exams by tutors and greedy College
authorities I do not want to reform the
tripos but destroy it but neither I nor
anyone else will succeed in doing so
since the Practical difficulties would
be so serious and the force of tradition
is so terribly strong some things have
changed since 1926. Hardy's view is that
the tripods should produce research
mathematicians but not everyone studying
math has that aim the modern day tripos
website is proud that the course
prepares students for a range of jobs
not just Academia let me show you one
more interesting past paper this was the
first page of the tripos exam in 1890
and was the exam taken by Philippa
Fawcett she wasn't the first woman to
sit the math tripos but was the first to
rank number one as the results of the
exam were announced the men's result
adults were read first and then the
woman's women weren't officially ranked
but were placed relative to the men the
faucet was placed above the senior
Wrangler and Senate house erupted in
celebration she beat the senior Wrangler
by 400 marks and her success was
headline news it took another 58 years
before women were actually allowed to
receive degrees from Cambridge today the
results are read out in alphabetical
order rather than by rank but what do
you think does the tripos deserve to be
destroyed as Hardy wanted or is it a
worthy challenge that motivates students
to perform at their best
thanks for watching and a special thank
you to my patreon supporters including
today's patreon cats of the day pen and
tilt